Goods arrive at the single Market by the
truckload
but with not enough banknotes in
circulation Traders are struggling to
find buyers for their goods
people from rural areas who used to buy
a thousand cartons of goods with cash
can no longer do that most of them are
unbanked
in October last year Nigeria's Central
Bank announced the redesign of the
highest denominations of the local
currency the naira
the bank then took the banknotes out of
circulation to discourage their use
that's left millions of Nigerians
queuing at banks for months desperate
for the new notes
there isn't enough money to go around
commercial banks have set cash
withdrawal limits to just 20 dollars
sometimes they have no cash to dispense
at all
informal trade makes up 60 of Nigeria's
economy and most transactions take place
in cash a shortage of banknotes and an
unreliable money transfer system are
making life difficult for small
businesses
Umar blames the government's monetary
and fiscal policies for the near
collapse of his business
difficult to feed my family as we speak
I only have 50 cents in the shop I don't
even have enough to give the shop
assistant money to catch a bus home
Nigeria Supreme Court has intervened and
ordered the central bank to put the old
notes back into circulation until the
end of the year
that was after some Governors to both
the central bank and federal government
to court when the economy goes down and
you need to activate it you reflect it
not deflate it what happened is like
deflating the economy and it is impacted
negatively on the people
economy is one of dangers ahead for an
economy that's already seen two
recessions in eight years
once economies experiencing this
simply means that the economy
can collapse at any time
and then before you Ginger people to
production again it will take time
because that trust on government and its
policies is no longer there
despite the order from the Supreme Court
the cash crunch continues it's causing
economic pain to millions of Nigerians
and small businesses how many degrees Al
Jazeera kanu Nigeria